well when it comes to activism
conservatives operate at a considerable
disadvantage I think the left
monopolizes many areas of the culture
perhaps none more than this this field
of activism they have structures in
place that allow them to organize their
activist activities
quickly and effectively they have armies
of paid astroturfed protesters ready to
be mobilized at a moment's notice they
have of course the entire corporate
media in their pocket always there to
promote their efforts Drive attendance
and then give their events glowing news
coverage after the fact but their
greatest Advantage which is perhaps a
consequence of everything I just listed
is that leftists in general are more
prone to get involved in activism in the
first place it comes to it comes to them
more naturally I guess you could say
conservatives are far more reluctant to
get involved in these sorts of things
either because they don't see the
Practical benefit of it or because
they're worried about the blowback or
because the whole idea is just too weird
and foreign to them or some combination
of these the end result is that activism
is a weapon an extremely effective
weapon wielded almost exclusively by one
side of the ideological divide the major
exception is the pro-life movement which
does manage to hold a massive barge once
a year but outside of that activism on
the right tends usually to be a small
um sort of disjointed affair
I'm well acquainted with these
challenges having been involved in
right-wing activism over the years and
it was uh front of Mind a few weeks ago
when we announced our plans to hold a
rally in Nashville
calling for an end to child gender
transitions otherwise uh referred to
more appropriately as child mutilation
it's a considerable risk to put together
an event like this in the cultural
context just described
the most disastrous and embarrassing
possible outcome is that only a couple
hundred people show up and and then the
problem is that you end up making a
statement very much contrary to the one
you set out to make you wanted to show
that lots of people support this idea
but then only a few people are there and
it doesn't really work out many
conservative rallies and marches have
suffered such a fate
and not necessarily because there aren't
many people who agree with whatever
they're rallying around but just because
of the reasons I already listed they
that they are just aren't showing up
so it's a risk but it was a risk worth
taking and I'm happy to report now in
hindsight that uh the risk did pay off
in a big way for us so we held our rally
outside the capitol here in Nashville on
Friday according to the official
estimates from the local police we ended
up with a crowd of around 3 000 people
now I can tell you that I was hoping for
at least one thousand I would have been
very happy with 1500 we doubled that
threshold in spite of the built-in
obstacles it was an enormously
successful event made all the better by
the compelling speakers we had on hand
Dr Colin Wright Tulsi gabbard Chloe Cole
Scott Nugent uh Robbie and Landon
Starbucks Senator Marsha Blackburn among
plenty of others all delivering
powerful defenses of Truth and Powerful
defenses of our children so we had we
had two primary goals for this rally one
was to further uh Inspire our state
lawmakers to follow through
legislatively and to legally ban child
mutilation in our state having spoken to
a number of them backstage at the rally
I can report that um
well they were officially inspired and
very impressed so that part
worked out I'm confident that the law
will get passed very quickly in this
state once the legislature is back in
session which will happen in a few weeks
the other goal was to spark a movement
that would extend beyond Tennessee and
inspire people across the country to
stand up against this madness and when I
say stand up against it I mean to take
to the streets to make themselves
visible to show up physically
not just on the internet
and I think we were successful in that
regard too but of course only time to
really tell the full story there are
certainly more needs to be done to turn
this into a national movement you can't
accomplish that with one rally of course
and I intend to stay very much involved
in that effort as we go across the
nation I don't think that I don't think
of myself as someone that was like Born
to Be an activist there's some people
who seem that way I don't see myself
that way it's not something that I've
ever felt myself especially
suited for but someone has to help lead
this charge and at least for now it
seems that job has fallen to me so be it
wasn't all sunshine and Roses though we
knew the left would do their best to
sabotage and derail our efforts and so
they did
leftist counter protesters were there on
Friday some of them certainly of the
paid variety some were armed antifa
members in tactical gear so they were
there and the rest were just this kind
of ragtag bunch of emotionally disturbed
Freaks and losers before it started one
counter protester with a hairstyle model
modeled I think after Heath Ledger's
Joker
explained that the guy who organized the
rally is a terrorist listen
[Music]
ERS
propaganda
and you support anything he says you are
indoctrinating everyone you know into
being a Nazi Matt Walsh is terrorists
[Music]
I just have to say one thing is that uh
if you want to go with the green hair
you you could you could do that as a
free country but the only problem is
that if you have green hair you have
officially precluded yourself
from ever calling someone else a lunatic
it just doesn't work you can't accuse
someone of lunacy while having green
hair
now he has no idea what the term
stochastic terrorist means because it
doesn't mean anything
but he's sure you know that I am one
whatever it means and that guy say
whatever else you want about him he was
actually rather reasonable and
respectful compared to the rest of the
graduates of the mutant Academy who
showed up witness for example this white
guy
screaming at another white person that
she is a white cracker who will burn in
hell
nobody knows who you are and nobody
cares and you will die alone you will
die alone and you will burn in hell
nobody knows who you are you'll die
alone
they really it's like you when you see
them screaming before you see the rest
of the cards you would think that they
were screaming at a mirror because the
everything they're saying perfectly
nobody knows who you are you will die
alone I could not think of a better uh
way to describe the person you just saw
in that video
and we see another of the advantages
actually that the left has in this world
this world of activism and you saw it
there in that video you know because you
had the guy screaming and then the woman
who was standing there
um the thing for the left is that so
many of them are sick deranged
freakazoids while the people who show up
on the other side are just normal human
beings they're tax paying citizens with
jobs and children
and many of them simply aren't prepared
to be confronted by green-haired
schizophrenics with bullhorns you saw
that woman she's like that's a normal
woman
now in that case she was she although
she was being verbally harassed and and
uh and verbally assaulted she handles it
quite well she handles it like a pro but
uh in general this is you know there are
lots of people who are just they see
something like this like I'm too normal
to be a part of this crowd as time went
on however the counter protesters they
didn't bother to articulate words
anymore instead they just started
screeching like brain damaged lizards
listen
[Music]
it makes a compelling argument you have
to admit
but not as compelling as this crew
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
man this is what happens if you don't
stay at home and raise your kids right
there that's that's what happens you
want your kids turn into that you want
to be disgraced and ashamed for the rest
of your life because that's what your
children turned into
Now They carried on with this routine
during the event uh trying to drown out
the speakers and prevent us from being
heard and you know at most rallies and
marches especially if it's for a leftist
cause counter protesters have to stand
off around the perimeter so that the
group that obtained the permit for the
space can hold their event that's part
of the whole point of like getting a
permit which we did but for our rally
for whatever reason the city allowed the
leftist trolls to come right into the
middle of the crowd uh with bullhorns
and sirens and vulgar chants and all the
rest of it
they continued even when they continue
for the entire event even when uh for
example Chloe Cole got up to speed
because she's an 18 year old
d-transitioner
who came to share her own experiences
her own rather horrifying experiences
with gender transition
um she's a victim of medical malpractice
and came to talk about that
the leftist trolls and the crowd
responded by chanting Fu fascists the
whole time she was speaking
to a traumatized 18 year old girl
now Chloe continued on uh I think
heroically unfazed none of our speakers
were rattled or flustered by the
commotion and we all managed to be heard
above the Demonic shrieking in fact as I
said from the stage on Friday
in the end I have to be grateful that
the disgusting Health spawns did show up
because it provided exactly the kind of
contrast
that I want people to see on one hand
you have normal decent Americans of all
ages and demographics
speaking out against one of the great
atrocities of our time and on the other
hand you have a bunch of screeching
goblins who have no argument to present
no point to make and are only interested
in silencing The Other Side by whatever
means necessary
so it's just it's up to each member of
the public to decide whose side they
want to be on so you see that footage
you decide who who do you want to line
up with
of course it is after the event
um that the leftist vultures really get
to work the freaks go home to their
parents houses and the media takes over
um the media's first priority and
favored strategy for something like this
is to just ignore any conservative March
or rally if they can this is what they
do with the March for Life 500 000
people are out there they just pretend
it didn't exist and that's what they
they prefer to Simply pretend
that it never happened and let its
memory quickly fade away but in our case
the event was big and loud and
impressive enough that ignoring it was
not an option so they scrambled to plan
B which is to blatantly lie and
mischaracterize the tennesseans article
on the rally is representative I think
listen to this paragraph This is what's
in the article quote
the so-called rally to end child
mutilation an event organized by the
conservative daily wire blog this event
drew a Motley crowd of about 1500
anti-transgender rights activists
pro-transgender rights activists proud
boys people protesting circumcision and
a variety of other right and
left-leaning political activists
okay so they call the daily wire a Blog
they cut our crowd size in half and then
they pretend that the crowd was
essentially an equal assortment of
people on both the right and left in
truth of course we outnumbered the
counter protesters by probably 20 to 1.
if not more than that
there are probably dozens of media
reports about the rally and nearly all
of them use these same tactics another
favorite strategy is this one by an AP
reporter she tweeted she tweeted this
along with a video she says very bizarre
scene here in Nashville today Matt Walsh
Tulsi gabbard Senator Blackburn and
other Republicans are scheduled to hold
a rally calling to ban gender affirming
care for minors trans right supporters
are in the crowd it appears country
music is blaring to drown them out she
follows that with this odd claim she
says there's an argument to be made that
this rally is really just to praise Matt
Walsh
yeah I hold up held a rally the praise
Matt Walsh rally so that's that's not
dissident that's uh we're doing that in
two months
there's also you know so that's there's
an argument to be made for that she says
there's also an argument to be made that
that you know you are a political
propagandist masquerading as a
journalist Kimberly
and the difference is that there's
evidence to support that argument
but the main point is that Kimberly made
sure to tweet footage of the crowd taken
before the event started
there's a lot of this on the left they
showed up like an hour hour and a half
early started taking pictures of the
crowd an hour before it even started and
they said look at this it's hardly
anyone here
at a time when you know a half or
two-thirds of the attendees hadn't
showed up yet and then as soon as
everybody was there the event was
happening you noticed that they stopped
tweeting pictures of the crowd it's
interesting how that works Kimberly
eventually published an article for the
AP claiming of course that hundreds of
people were there rather than thousands
who were actually there but she also
which interesting thing is that in the
article she only mentions my name once
as an aside while listing the speaker
she goes through the whole argument at
the very end she says and there are
other speakers there too including Matt
Walsh and yada yada
but on Twitter she was convinced that
the entire rally was about me
which is it
but you know why should the propagandist
pick one lie or the other there's no
reason to you don't have to settle on
one when you can have them all that's
the benefit of being a liar I suppose
it's only if you're if you care about
the truth that you have to worry about
things like consistency but you know
lies you could tell any lie you want
all in all
between the media's lies and the left's
attempts to sabotage us
one message comes through loud and clear
and the message is that we are winning
okay
they're throwing everything they can
against the wall because we are
succeeding
we have all the momentum right now and
they know it
and they're afraid
and they should be
now
they still Harbor delusions that these
kinds of tactics will um
scare us away
and and the thing is maybe they have
reason to think that because in the past
they have been able to intimidate
conservatives by screaming in their face
lying about them in the media on and on
but not this time
because we aren't those kinds of
conservatives
that was a different era of conservatism
weren't a new era now this is a new
breed you're dealing with guys
and we're not going away
this is just the beginning
and that'll do it for us today as we
move over to the members block of the
show hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you